issue facing every american household
the labor department says inflation has
hit a 31-year high with prices rising to
more than double we've seen in recent
decades nancy cordes is following this
from the white house where president
says it's a top priority to get
inflation under control
new government figures show beef prices
are up 20 percent since last year
furniture up 12 percent
new cars nearly 10 percent the largest
one-year increase since 1975.
even rent for the average apartment has
shot up by more than 100 dollars a month
cover 19 has stretched global supply
chains like never before in baltimore
wednesday president biden insisted the
problem is temporary and touted the 17
billion dollars in the newly passed
infrastructure bill that will go towards
modernizing ports
but that won't happen fast enough to
ease the current supply crunch we've got
higher demand for goods at the same time
we're facing disruptions in the supplies
to make those goods prices typically
rise about two to three percent a year
but over the past year they've shot up
more than six percent it's not just a
u.s problem this is a global problem
moody's chief economist mark zandy says
he thinks inflation should dissipate in
2022 if we keep the pandemic at bay are
there certain big ticket items that you
would say
don't buy that right now
wait six months or a year you'll get a
better price
cars vehicles i mean
to be real though even if you wanted to
buy one you might not be able to find
one there's only believe it or not
there's only 75 000
cars on dealer lots today in a typical
time it's closer to 500 000
how's that for a shortage and because
everything is connected it's due in
large part to another shortage for the
kinds of computer chips that are used in
automobiles so it gives you a sense of
why these problems are not going to be
unwound overnight in fact zandy says
that even if inflation starts to improve
next year it could take two years to
unwind all of these supply chain backups
nate
just hold off on the car shop and nancy
thank you